[Musique]
coc
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
point de vue je vous présente les deux
invités qui ont accepté d'y participer
gabriel cluzel bonjour vous êtes
rédactrice en chef du site boulevard
voltaire et écrivain votre dernier livre
enraciné nous sommes tous les héritiers
a été publié aux éditions arte jean
février 2020 avec nous également ce soir
gilles smadja bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directeur de cabinet du maire de
nanterre et ancien rédacteur en chef à à
l'humanité alors voilà les les deux
thèmes qui ont retenu notre attention
aujourd'hui premier thème faut-il taxer
davantage les riches et le deuxième
thème les excuses du maire de poitiers
sont-elles convaincante on démarre tout
de suite c'est une proposition qui
revient régulièrement depuis le début de
l'économie finalement pour résoudre la
dette liée à la l'épidémie de kovy d'
une seule solution taxer les riches je
vois que gilles smadja l'oeil qui frise
hier soir encore l'économiste thomas
piketty revenu à la charge c'était sur
france 5
voilà en résumé ce qu'ils disaient tous
les grands épisodes de dette publique
il évoquait les guerres et l'après
guerre nous ont conduits à mettre à
contribution les très hauts revenus les
plus fortunés alors gilles smadja en
écoutant les propositions de thomas
piketty vous vous dites c'est la bonne
solution
en tout cas on peut se dire que c'est ce
qui déjà ce qui se fait ailleurs par
exemple aux états unis qui n'est
pourtant pas un modèle de pays
collectiviste et voilà et bien le
nouveau président américain joe biden y
revoilà décidé par exemple de solliciter
davantage les bénéfices des entreprises
il a décidé de les taxer davantage + 7 %
il a décidé de solliciter les hauts
revenus qui ont quatre cent mille
dollars annuels c'est quand même on peut
bien vivre avec 400 mille dollars donc
au dessus de 400 mille dollars il a
décidé de les taxer davantage
franchement aujourd'hui je crois que
c'est oui c'est tout à fait il est
logique dans une période comme celle là
et bien les plus grandes fortunes les
plus hauts revenus soit davantage mis à
contribution
que ceux qui ont qui gagnent moins pour
pour relancer le pays pour essayer de de
retrouver voilà lutter contre les
inégalités relancer l'économie oui c'est
c'est tout à fait c'est dans l'ordre des
choses
gabriel cluzel c'est la bonne solution
pour réduire cette dette qui a explosé
non je pense que c'est le mantra qui
fait plaisir c'est vrai qu'on se
souvient de l'impôt la taxe jean valjean
qu'avait voulu lancer vincent lindon
c'est vrai que ça fait plaisir à taxco
êtes l'impôt copains des bois on peut
tous les faire cesser
c'est ce que je dirai que c'est assez
démagogique tout le monde a envie que
les riches mettre la main au
portefeuille le permet de savoir qui est
riche
si c'est effectivement bill gates
d'ailleurs il s'est proposé gentiment de
donner quelques en dames patronnesses
quelques sous effectivement ça n'émeut
pas grand monde et on se dit qu'il a les
moyens mais en réalité en france quand
on veut taxer et bien on taxe qu'on a
sous la main et on se rend compte que
les gens riches plus vous êtes riche
pour votre argent et mobile est volatile
et en fait les grandes fortunes les très
grandes fortunes les vraies grandes
fortunes échappe finalement à l'impôt
français celui ci sera bas très vite sur
que le bas de laine du français moyen de
la qualité fourmiz c'est un peu ce qu'on
a dit durant cette crise c'est vrai que
les français n'ont pas dépensé déjà
parce que j'ai vingt certain nombre de
secteurs comme les loisirs le tourisme
etc dans lequel n'avait plus lieu de
dépenser et puis parce que c'est un
réflexe légitime de bon père de famille
ou de bonnes mères de famille mais on va
me faire écharper par les féministes
c'est et c'est à dire que quand on ne
sait pas de quoi l'avenir est fait on
met de côté alors dire que la fourmi et
riches n'ont pas nécessairement donc je
crois que au contraire c'est quelque
chose qui qui c'est quelque chose qui
peut inquiéter les français de lancer
cette idée là dans l'absolu et encore
une fois on va taxer ce qui est
finalement dans notre pays
enraciné sans la faire de la publicité
les petites de mon aimé le lol on l'a vu
du reste cette c'est une tentation
permanente
on l'a parce que dans l'imaginaire
français il ya des grandes fortunes
immobilières alors qu'aujourd'hui les
grandes fortunes
encore une fois son mobilier
et pas fixé en france on va les faire
fuir si si si si on les taxe
donc je crois que metref il faut non
simplement pour dire effectivement s'il
faut faire quelque chose
c'est pousser les gens qui ont de
l'argent à investir dans des capitaux
propres dans des du capital
d'entreprises de capital des pme
à l'heure du conte à l'occasion de cette
crise qui allait reconstruire le pays
mais dans ces cas il ya un capital qui
reste en france et qui est franco
française sans ajout de la mention la
question où le savoir est ce que pour la
préco vide
est-ce que la relance économique voilà
du pays est ce que parce ça passe par un
plan de relance qui serait financée par
une taxation des plus riches ou par une
taxation des grandes entreprises
alors là je dis ça ne peut pas être la
seule voix ça ne peut pas être la seule
voie évidemment d'ailleurs la question
se pose et je pense qu'aujourd'hui des
économistes très sérieux la pose de
savoir s'il n'est pas préférable de
travailler à un effacement de la dette
c'est-à-dire de considérer qu'on a été
de l'annulation de la dette oui vous
l'avez l'autre certain nombre
d'économistes très sérieux des vins de
travail là dessus
tout simplement parce qu'on est dans une
situation totalement exceptionnel que et
que donc il est que comme toute façon ça
a touché absolument toute l'europe voire
le monde
en tout cas au niveau de l'union
européenne il serait peut-être oui ce
serait peut-être approprié de travailler
sur ce schéma là une sortie de crise
qu'ils fassent qu'on annule la dette et
qu'on reparte à zéro vous ne croyez pas
que ce que dit par un peu bruno le maire
que la croissance économique peut
suffire à a diminué cette dette est loin
de là elle ne permettra pas de de
relever les grandes les deux grands
défis qui sont devant nous c'est à dire
le défi social est le défi écologique
parce qu'on sait très bien
on sait très bien que la croissance
elles ne génèrent elles ne génèrent pas
automatiquement la réduction des
inégalités sociales voire parfois elle
l'accroît elle ne génère pas
automatiquement la la de la réduction de
l'empreinte carbone et de la réduction
des de toutes les causes qui sont à
l'origine de la crise climatique donc la
croissance aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il ne faut plus avoir un
point de vue dogmatique sur la
croissance gelé longtemps eu j'ai
longtemps pensé que la croissance était
automatiquement générer de l'emploi de
la réduction des inégalités
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus vrai c'est
plus vrai ce n'est plus vrai aujourd'hui
gabriel cluzel cette idée d'effacer la
dette d'annuler la dette ça vous paraît
quelque chose qui est réalisable
je pense surtout que ça aix est
profondément inquiétant et anxiogène
pour tous ceux qui finalement
investissent dans un certain nombre de
produits financiers qui malgré tout ont
leur utilité pour soutenir l'économie et
qui voit cette perspective d'un oeil
extrêmement soucieux et on peut les
comprendre
et puis c'est vrai que dans l'absolu une
dette et fait quand même pour pour être
remboursé moi je crois que il faut
changer de paradigme dans ce pays et
c'est à dire que il faut se dire que
pour qu'il y ait des oeufs d'or il faut
pas tuer la poule et nous souffrons
contrairement aux pays anglo saxons dans
notre pays quand même d'un désamour pour
pour le riche qui évite et l'épargnant
encore une fois est vite assimilé aux
riches donc non je crois que précisément
que pour reconstruire le pays il faut
orienter vers des investissements
pourquoi pas mais pas dans une démarche
de fiscalité c'est à dire on a déjà une
fiscalité qui est extrêmement écrasante
dans une démarche d'incitation à
peut-être à consommer à investir dans
des activités qui vont reprendre
je pense par exemple je le disais tout à
l'heure ce qui a beaucoup de souffert
c'est le tourisme et les loisirs le nom
est essentielle puisque seul l'essentiel
a été maintenue il est évident que vous
ne vous offrez du dieu de du non
essentiels que quand vous avez un tout
petit peu plus que nécessaire sur sur
votre compte donc ce secteur là ne
repartira que si on laisse cette marche
supérieure mais pas disposé à
disposition la disposition des gens non
on a vu que la fiscalité
punitive n'avait absolument aucun
intérêt l'état a déjà mis 400 milliards
je crois dans la table pour soutenir le
quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est un peu une illusion c'est vous
savez où comme vous et moi c'est une
formule rhétorique parce qu'à la fin il
en coûtera ce qui se tient dans la poche
des français donc cesser c'est
extrêmement important de relancer on dit
vous savez on connaît vous connaissez le
proverbe chinois qui dit vaut mieux
apprendre un un pêcheur a péché que lui
donner du poisson est là en l'occurrence
il vaut mieux l'aider à acheter une
canne à pêche
donc moi je crois alors c'est vrai que
monsieur va me trouver infiniment
libéral et pourtant cela semble tracée
au coin du bon sens et par exemple on
dit que les ps2 sûr que si vous parle
marathon et non non on dit que les
pelles et les ailes l on a comparé
beaucoup la france à l'allemagne durant
cette crise en disant que nous
finalement nous avions investi dans les
grands grands groupes qui s'était
délocalisé qui nous ont fait perdre
notre souveraineté
alors que l'allemagne avait gardé cpm et
pour aider les pme c'est pour ça je
voulais donner un exemple après je cède
la parole eh bien il faut par exemple
alléger les charges sociales on sait
bien qu'elle en crève tout et que
souvent messalisants kenzo croit topo
pour faire faire le lien est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un problème quand même malgré
tout de ras-le-bol fiscal c'est-à-dire
que vous évoquez l'idée de taxer les
riches
finalement ça a été un des sujets d'une
campagne en 2012 ou françois hollande
dit on va taxer les riches mais à la fin
c'est la grèce moyenne qu'ils peuvent
voir et c'est la classe moyenne qui est
inquiet comme comment on est vite ça est
un peu de changements écoutez le
bon on va pas dire le dogme on va dire
l'espèce de petit manuel de libéralisme
que
vous me resservir heureux sortait
régulièrement ici c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui est mis en oeuvre depuis al yousif
oui oui mais c'est ce qui me vient c'est
ce qui est mis en oeuvre par emmanuel
macron depuis quatre ans avant emmanuel
macron par françois hollande pendant
cinq ans avant françois hollande par
nicolas sarkozy pendant cinq ans et
franchement ça va mieux aujourd'hui le
pays va mieux
le pays va mieux attendez laissez moi
terminer le pays le pays à moins
d'inégalités sociales
il ya moins de chômage il ya non les
choses se sont encore accentuées
il ya encore davantage de gens qui
souffrent qui n'y arrive pas qu ils ne
s'en sortent pas alors peut-être qu'on
pourrait peut-être essayer de faire
autre chose donc peut-être qu'il serait
peut-être temps de se dire peut-être
qu'il ya peut-être une autre façon
d'aborder alors moi j'avais séché
drapeau par un jeune homme je ne
présente pas la taxation des riches
comme comme l'alpha et l'oméga de
l'économie mais franchement si on a six
ont transposé à la france ce que byden
fait aux états unis alors c'est à dire
regardez il dit l'air les gens qui ont
des revenus supérieurs à 400 mille
dollars
on va les taxer davantage imaginons
qu'on fasse ça en france pour les gens
qui ont des revenus supérieurs annuelle
supérieure à 400 mille euros par an
c'était exactement la proposition entre
parenthèses de jean-luc mélenchon à
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
et bien si on taxer davantage les gens
qui ont plus qui ont plus de 400000
euros par an pour est venu franchement
et vous les accès seront bien bas
voulons les taxes à 70 80 90 broadley de
400 mille quatre cent quatre ans mais
franchement avec quatre cent mille euros
vous pouvez bien vivre non par an alors
on les mettra pas sur la paille vous
nous faites la transition parfaite avec
justement joe biden qui ne propose pas
que c'est d'augmenter les impôts des
plus riches
je vous propose d'écouter jeannette
jelen la secrétaire américaine au trésor
parce que dans le package fait une
augmentation d'une taxe va la création
d'une taxe mondiale à 21% ce qui permet
de taxer les gaffes à ce que ce qu'on
cherche à faire de plan à ris que taxer
les gars fans notamment à travers cette
taxe mondiale ça peut être une solution
qui permettrait d'éviter de taxer les
citoyens et non mais évidemment tout le
monde est là aussi et qui est contre
taxer les gaffes à les gaffes a
évidemment tout le monde veut les taxer
mais ce serait bien si masisi le
gouvernement de dubaï dan y arrive mais
on sait très bien qu au bout du bout
c'est pas ça qui va se passer
vous me dites oui on a fait ça avec
macron avec hollande avec et ensuite je
vous parlais jo bagdad mais en réalité
vous êtes exactement comme eux quand
vous quand quand vous comparez et joe
biden pour moi parce que dubaï fait une
politique pour les états unis qui ne
sont évidemment pas qui en cure qui sont
dans une situation de domination sur
tous les plans et notamment économique
qui n'est évidemment pas celui de la
france nous ne sommes pas ne sont pas là
la grenouille qui veut se faire aussi
grosse que le boeuf et le problème c'est
que tout ce qui a été fait ces airs vers
deux dernières années elle a été fait
dans une optique absolument mondialiste
en croyant à la vertu de la main du
marché qui effectivement nous a
profondément nui et aujourd'hui nous
nous retrouvons nu comme un ver et cette
crise c'est a été un catalyseur un
révélateur de toutes les insuffisances
évidemment du mondialisme et aujourd'hui
emmanuel vacants qui s'est mis dans la
main de l'europe pour et par les chaînes
de valeur sur les produits dans la main
du monde entier se retrouvent démunis
alors comparer avec jonah hill john nous
avec la politique de giovanni delle me
paraît tout à fait malvenu pour la
simple raison que nous ne sommes pas des
états unis au contraire si nous
réinvestissons si nous faisons un plan
de réindustrialisation
il devra veiller à protéger la france
cela dit
à d'autres fils puisque vous traitiez
libéral c'est vrai non c'est pas une
qualification va pas et je pense à cette
phrase de margaret thatcher vous savez
qu'il disait qu'il disait moi mon père
m'avait appris à retourner les
enveloppes mon père épicier je crois
elle est donc quand il était au 10
downing street elle elle retourne et les
enveloppes pour les utiliser deux fois
alors pourquoi je vous raconte ça parce
que j'ai d'autres références que
margaret thatcher
heureusement ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il ya aussi des économies voit
l'avenir c'est à dire qu'on a des délais
publique pléthorique on voit un
millefeuille administratif
là aussi qui est non alors et dans
lequel on peut plus chiadé il ya des
fraudes sociales dans lequel on pourrait
piocher également donc tout cela il a
exploré avant de sortir ce mantra il
faut taxer les riches vous savez alors
un autre sujet de la dépense publique on
n'arrête pas de là c'est le fait c'est
le dogme de la réduction de la dépense
publique que vous défendez c'est ce
dogme là qui a fait qu'on a supprimé 60
mille lits dans les hôpitaux en france
ou alors ces découvertes annoncées ici
c'est exactement ce qu'on veut c'est
votre spectacle
c'est exactement ça non mais c'est bon
alors vous reviendrez sur une autre sera
notre thème parce que je pense que la
réduction de la dépense publique
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir on vous a
interrogé chez vous pour savoir s'il
fallait taxer les riches pour faire face
à la crise du coc vide c'est non à 55 7%
oui 44,3 effectivement c'est assez serré
lui sasserno plus inhibé voyez qu'on est
beaucoup plus divers mais bel et bien le
pensiez alors nicole nous dit en france
c'est toujours la classe moyenne qui
paye c'est un peu le fectivement l'a
abordée romano dit bien sûr qu'il faut
taxer les riches tout le monde doit
contribuer à la mesure de sa richesse
lucie en revanche ne s'est accéléré je
reviendrai à faire fuir les derniers
ce n'est pas la bonne solution et
sylvain civens nous dit il faudrait
supprimer les niches fiscales
quand l'autre conclut pas de bol pour la
france nous avons déjà la fiscalité la
plus élevée
alors je vous propose de passer au
second thème qui sans transition
d'ailleurs parce que on aura du mal à
faire un lien sur les corps que les
excuses je sais pas si on peut les
qualifier comme ça de la maire de
poitiers la semaine dernière les aux
normes ont conduit la mer et qu'europe
écologie les verts avait créé la
polémique je vous propose dans un
premier temps d'écouter les premiers
propos ce qu'elle a tenus lors du
conseil municipal du 29 mars
aujourd'hui l'argent public doit envoyer
un signal de responsabilité compte tenu
du fait que ça ne menace pas la survie
d'associations aujourd'hui nous
considérons que l'argent public ne doit
plus financer la l'espoir fondé sur la
consommation de ressources épuisables
mettre dans le même phrase rêve d'enfant
et le fait de sauver des clubs aérien je
trouve que ça a quelque chose d'indécent
en fait les rien c'est triste mais ne
doit plus faire partie des rêves
d'enfants aujourd'hui
alors ça c'était le 29 mars et je vous
propose d'écouter son correctif ce matin
sur rtl
je suis tout à fait consciente de la
maladresse de cette phrase et de
l'incompréhension qu'elle a pu générer
chez les personnes est en effet
aujourd'hui je cette cause mérite d'être
défendue avec des termes peut-être plus
plus adroits vraiment je comprends
qu'elle ait pu générer de la
compréhension toute ma vie engagée pour
offrir des rêves vos enfants dans
l'éducation populaire notamment celles
et les premières décisions que nous
avons prises en arrivant à poitiers donc
on ne peut absolument pas me reprocher
de vouloir briser les rêves des enfants
le débat se situe ailleurs c'est une
question de responsabilité écologique
royal que l'usl vous êtes convaincu par
ses excuses si on peut les appeler comme
ça je suis convaincu qu'elle a été
surprise par la l'ampleur de la réaction
ça c'est évident et qu'elle ne le voyais
pas venir aujourd'hui c'est la magie des
réseaux sociaux c'est à dire que vous
pensez un peu à l'abri dans votre
conseil municipal et puis il ya un petit
extrait qui sait que d'un but comme ça
et qui tel un scud
donc ça ça ne l'a pas vu venir bien là
malheureusement pour eux on pourrait
penser que c'est simplement maladroit si
ça ne rentrait pas dans une logique
globale telle que nous l'ont montré
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de maires
écolo pour parler vulgairement et qui
sont un peu accrédite valide la thèse
d'un de ces mer rouge dans certains les
lll les qualifie que certain c'est que
certains les qualifie donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu le sapin de noël il ya eu on
l'a dit à plusieurs fois il ya eu le
tour de france mais rajoutent en rien
les revoilà donc là il ya des rêves
d'enfants serait de toucher au rêve
d'enfance et ses essais c'est quand même
même daniel cohn bendit cohn bendit s'en
était lui ému mais rappelons que déjà on
a de la chance parce que souvenez vous
que yves cochet avait même proposé de
supprimer les enfants eux mêmes d'une
certaine façon puisqu'il avait suggéré
vous savez quand même membre fondateur
sauf erreur de ma part d'europe écologie
les verts et avait supprimé de limiter
les naissances lui voilà donc bientôt il
ya plus de rêves d'enfant puis bientôt
il y aura peut-être eu d'enfant du tout
parce que les enfants ça pollue donc il
voulait qu'on supprime les allocations
familiales à partir du troisième enfant
pour pour dissuader les gens d'avoir des
enfants alors évidemment en plus le
calendrier fort malvenu puisque ça tombe
précisément au moment de la cause de
cette controverse autour de la dette de
la mosquée de strasbourg ce que la mer
est écolo de strasbourg a fait effet
fait voter une subvention pour le moins
polémique donc
et là aussi ça a créé dit un autre
comment dire une un autre cliché écolo
c'est à dire celui de la la pastèque qui
ne vous le connaissez sûrement rouge à
l'intérieur vers l'extérieur alors
voilà peut-être que ça donnera un coup
d'arrêt à cette espèce d'écologie folle
parce que c'est pas un procès de
l'écologie nous sommes tous un peu écolo
vous moi vous également je perds je sais
la dérive et écoute exactement regard de
gens de bonne foi qui ont voté pour eux
et qu'ils doivent être aujourd'hui
parfaitement éberlué de voir toutes ces
suggestions à ses joueurs juste avant
que vous preniez la parole je vous donne
les chiffres
de nos internautes des tweetos êtes vous
convaincu par les excuses de la maire de
poitiers non à 90,0 vous avez été
convaincu je n'aurai pas le j'ai été
convaincu par le sur le fond de sa
décision sur le fond oui et je vais vous
dire pourquoi sont la lanterne les
inventions
c'est à dire le fait de lire aujourd'hui
on ne peut plus subventionner un certain
nombre d'activités qui sont des
activités qui génèrent et bien un modèle
qui est le modèle de le modèle du monde
d'avant c'est à dire du monde d'avant la
crise climatique du monde d'avant la
prise de conscience qu'il est temps
d'agir pour essayer de réduire oui les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre les
émissions carbone alors qu'elles
abordent quoi comme sujet elle dit voilà
dans le sport aujourd'hui il ya des
activités sportives qui malheureusement
sont aujourd'hui des activités qui kivu
ne vont pas dans le sens de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique au
contraire qu'il qui les aggrave
et c'est un sujet que je connais bien
parce que j'ai eu à m'occuper de ça il
ya qu il ya quelque temps et je peux
vous dire par exemple quand j'étais au
cabinet du ministre des sports je peux
vous dire que c'est un problème majeur
et je suis d'autant plus à l'aise pour
vous en parler que par exemple moi je
suis un passionné de course automobile
j'ai grandi dans le rêve des pilotes qui
s'appelait jim clark graham hill ayrton
senna alain prost et voilà et donc ça
m'a fait rêver je suivais ça le dimanche
devant la télé j'étais passionné voilà
de quoi arrêter mais bien sûr qu'il faut
à lui d'une saison formule 1 en france
mais non une saison de formule 1 une
saison de formule 1 ces deux cent
soixante mille tonnes deux cent soixante
mille tonnes de co2 et d'ailleurs il
n'ya quasiment plus un grand pays
aujourd'hui qui veut à certains
affichages en matière de d'écologie qui
n'accueille de grand prix de formule 1
les grands prix de formule 1 ils ont
lieu dans des dans des coins très
exotique ou l'art l'écologie on s'en
fout totalement bahreïn
malaisie qatar il veut retenir iéna d'au
moins un lien n'a franchement y'a de la
raison moi et d'ailleurs vous savez que
ce sont les grands pilotes et les grands
les grandes écuries qui aujourd'hui rue
réfléchissent à une transition par
exemple alain prost il est à l'origine
du grandes villes détruites de la
formule électrique
c'est d'ailleurs a été accueilli à paris
donc je voudrais la région voilà alors
on vient là dessus sur le fond mais la
frêle raison sur le fond c'est à dire il
faut absolument que le sport comme toute
activité humaine soit aujourd'hui
résolument tourné vers vers l'écologie
vers la transition écologique on peut
plus vivre dans un monde où le kérosène
le kérosène
et bien c'est pas un problème d'avoir un
monde de kérosène à tout-va non oui
c'est un problème est bien sûr qu'il va
falloir réduire le mode de transport
aérien évidemment bien sûr qu'il va
falloir le faire et d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs il va il serait bien que
dans le plan de relance de la france en
investissent massivement dans la
recherche sur des énergies alternatives
qu'on investisse massivement sur le
développement de l'industrie automobile
électrique qu'on investisse massivement
sur d'autres formes énergétique que
celle qui alors transition écologique du
coup vous convient puisque elle est
tellement loin de 2 des nécessités
aujourd'hui tellement loin de ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour réellement passé
être au niveau des défis à relever donc
sur le fond elle a raison
après moi je pense que quand on est un
dirigeant politique en mer voilà je
pense qu'il faut se garder de mettre les
enfants dans des dents des comparaisons
dans des références je pense qu'en
général c'est pas terrible
voilà c'est pas terrible et là bon elle
s'est pris les pieds dans le tapis
oui mais vous savez il est aussi le
procédé qui consiste à sortir 30
secondes du coin d'un conseil municipal
qui dure trois heures
bon ça non plus c'est pas terrible
il faut il faut que les maires fasse
attention ils savent que maintenant tout
est enregistré tout et diffusable
quand vous voyez vous avait listé les
quelques dérapages si on peut les
appeler comme ça des maires il ya les
régionales qui peuvent se tenir en juin
il ya des accords qui montrent que les
écolos à tête de d'union de la gauche
peuvent diriger des régions ça vous fait
peur ou dit c'est des mairies puissance
vain puisque pour le coup les budgets
sont beaucoup plus importants ben en
effet je pense que ça peut amener les
électeurs à réfléchir c'est à dire a
rejeté un autre regard sur ces
politiques écolo qui donnait peu tard
envoyé peut-être une image de gentil de
jean de florette et en réalité on se
rend compte qu'il ya une idéologie sous
tendu derrière bien plus bien plus forte
moi je ne peux pas entendre ce que vous
dites parce que nous ne sommes pas du
tout parmi les pays les plus polluants
on les connaît ce qui pollue alors
pourquoi nous faire de la surenchère
dans ce domaine là alors que la france
ne pollue pas je ne sais pas où ce
délire fou va nous emmener
on est presque dans la grande salle
culture ça bientôt saint-exupéry et
guînes mer vont être des bouts
déboulonner aussi est-ce que la cuisine
sur le gaz là aussi on va tous de voir
la gastronomie française
consommez fois bon mais ce nom mais
quand vous savez très bien que c'est
absurde d'un village je discutais
surtout que ça m'étonne beaucoup de
quelqu'un qui a une sensibilité de
gauche comme vous je discutais avec déjà
des chauffeurs de taxi qui me disaient
toutes les mesures autour des voitures
polluantes pour nous c'est un désastre
économique parce que on a investi dans
des voitures et trucks tous très bien
que tous les chauffeurs über etc sont
propriétaires de leur outil de travail
et ils se retrouvent ou dans
l'alternative détaxés ou de racheter
quelque chose à prix d'or c'est
absolument insupportable et et je suis
toujours étonné de voir que des gens
comme les écolos ou d'autres ceux qui
s'allient avec eux qui ont une
sensibilité de gauche font fi de tout
cela on ça a été dit et redit d'ailleurs
les voitures diesel en général cbc pas
cessé les gens l'ailé
les moins riches qui en possèdent une
dans l'idée de faire de les faire durer
donc tout cela est extrêmement
dérangeant alors je mets pas non plus en
reste et charitable enfin cette pauvre
parce que la balle à cette pauvre dame
qui s'en est pris plein la figure mais
s'ils voulaient les gens sont gentiment
aller chercher de son compte instagram
ont vu qu'elle était partie en tunisie
lui ont demandé si à la barque c'était
pas trop longue
donc il ya un moment il faut être
cohérent avec ce que l'on défend là en
plus était pas vous me disiez faut pas
mettre les enfants dans la boucle ce
n'était pas n'importe quel enfant du
reste et des enfants malades et
handicapés donc ça prend une dimension
encore supérieur c'est vrai vous avez
raison les réseaux sociaux sont cruels
mais ils ont ils ont quand même une
vertu c'est qui montre les choses sourit
les subventions d'associations sont
assez opaque très opaque même et je
pense qu'un certain nombre de gens dont
on l'a déjà dit du reste pour la mairie
de paris serait assez étonné de savoir
où vont leurs impôts donc peut-être
qu'elle avait des gages à donner à son
électorat peut-être qu'elle n'avait pas
envie que l'on dise que la maire écolo
continuer à subventionner un un aéroclub
j'en sais rien je serait intéressant de
savoir et ça nous éloigne à peine du
débat savoir toutes les associations
quelle que soit la taille de la ville
vous aimez la nature des associations on
va les faire que vous avez tort
d'opposer le fait d'être de gauche
au fait d'être écologiste vous avez tort
parce que ces deux c'est ce sont les
deux piliers aujourd'hui de la
transformation de la société à opérer
on ne peut pas moi oui vous avez raison
je suis de sensibilité de gauche
depuis longtemps et je suis je suis de
sensibilité aussi écologique parce que
je considère qu'on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui être de gauche
si l'on porte pas l'idée d'une
transformation écologique de la société
non pas pour être à la mode non pas pour
faire plaisir à une minorité de bobos de
pain une toute petite partie de la
population qui vivraient dans les
agglomérations à l'aise non pas du tout
parce qu'aujourd'hui n'est pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui la crise climatique le
désordre écologique c'est d'abord chez
les plus pauvres qu'il fait le plus de
dégâts
c'est chez les plus pauvres c'est
aujourd'hui le la crise climatique
elle frappe d'abord dans les pays les
plus les moins favorisés les moins
développés donc au jeu quand on est de
gauche oui il faut porter l'idée de la
transition écologique
parce que on l'un et l'autre ne peuvent
plus être séparés
et c'est chez moi une conviction forte
je ne vous dis pas que j'ai toujours eu
cette conviction
voilà c'est un cheminement mais parce
que je les ai acquise quand je vois
effectivement qu'aujourd'hui ce qui ce
qui par exemple souffrent le plus de
dépollution ceux qui souffrent le plus
de tous les effets de tous les effets
collatéraux de la crise climatique
eh bien je vois que massivement ce sont
les populations aussi les plus
défavorisés que les électeurs de gauche
sont convaincus comme vous ce que je
veux dire c'est que est-ce que ce qui se
passe depuis un an dans les mairies
alors c'est peut-être anecdotique mais
ça va faire peur à des électeurs de
gauche conserve maintenant on va pas
mettre ça à la tête des régionales ce
qui est vrai et ce qui est vrai c'est
que je pense que les un certain nombre
de maires et nouveau nouveau maire
écologiste comme notamment ceux de lyon
de bordeaux de bordeaux à l'âge je pense
que je crois qu'ils anecdotique trop
leur gestion municipale
alors à côté je pense qu'il ya des
choses qu'ils font et qui sont
extrêmement positives tout simplement
parce qu'il met en oeuvre le programme
sur lequel ils ont été élus et dans leur
programme
il ya des choses qui sont tout à fait
importante et qui vont qui veut qui
permettent aux villes d'évoluer dans le
bon sens mais à force de
justement de donner à du grain à moudre
à part des petites anecdotes comme les
sapins de noël ou voilà ça c'est
vraiment ça ne sert pas la cause quoi
voilà ça n'aide pas à mesurer l'année la
nécessité d'opérer vraiment une
transition écologique dans les communes
et on a absolument besoin de ça alors on
va terminer avec les quelques
expressions de nos amis internautes qui
nous suivent
jean-marc nous dit son premier jet donc
la première réaction de
de la maire de poitiers reflète bien sa
façon de pensée aucune excuse ne peut
réellement changer cela et l'eau nous
dit l'écologie est apolitique et pierre
les écologistes veulent une régression
pure et simple au lieu de promouvoir des
solutions en accord avec notre temps je
vous rappelle les chiffres du ce2 du
sondage immédiat non à 99 7% vous n'êtes
pas convaincus par les excuses de la
maire de poitiers
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur le
plateau de points de vue et à demain
pour une nouvelle émission
[Musique]